msnbc nobody watches it that's the
positive part of the story it's just
this ridiculous clown network for
brainwashed mpc people if you don't know
what the npc meme is you got to google
it it's fantastic npc is non-playable
character so these are the characters in
video games that nobody's controlling so
if you're in like a big world with all
of your friends and you're all real
people the npcs are the you know the
robots and all the characters that don't
they can't do much of anything they can
just kind of walk back and forth they
have they have no autonomy or anything
so npcs are sort of the blue pill people
who just can't really do anything they
just accept everything as it is can't
think on their own make any decisions
for themselves well msnbc
had a guest on i believe this is from
this morning and i think the host was
nicole wallace it's not even worth
knowing any of these people's names it
really isn't and i still i do struggle
with this thing about whether we should
show these things or not because it's
like we're getting more views me and my
two guys in here we're getting more
views than what msnbc is pulling in
despite massive budgets and pr and
entire machine behind it and everything
else but occasionally we just got to
show you how ridiculous these people are
so here's here's a guest he's a he's a
law professor or something at uh well
just watch the clip he's on with
nicole wallace talking about republicans
at elections what do you think happens
um jason you think they take the wrong
lessons
from the possibility that they have some
success they seem to be good at that as
well
well nicole i think they've they've
taken the right lessons and the right
lessons are you can rally people around
a lie based on white supremacy and
sexism and nationalism and homophobia
and everything else like that and a key
thing to understand why republicans are
optimistic next year even if they're
sort of waving themselves and wrapping
themselves in a trump burrito is they're
gonna cheat i mean they're just gonna
make voting laws throughout the country
that guarantee that they're gonna win
there are very few states right now
nicole where there is a very good act of
organizing republican party republican
party in georgia is in shambles because
they haven't had to work in so long they
just figure that they're going to pass
legislation and make it harder for
democrats to vote if the republican
party isn't really ready to run a
campaign outside of the midwest they
just figure if we can pass in the voter
suppression wrap ourselves in trump and
intimidate the other side we can win in
2022. oh pass voter suppression like
having ids to vote all right so the guy
there the guest again not that you need
to know these people's names jason
johnson he's an associate professor of
communication and journalism at morgan
state university he's also an msnbc
slash cnn commentator okay
zippity-dippity everything he said there
was fear-mongering nonsense yes the
republicans are all white supremacists
and sexists and racists and all of that
and then he talks about these fabricated
laws that republicans are going to pass
to cheat and it is what it's a hundred
percent lie it is 180 from the truth
republicans in texas and in georgia and
other places have tried to pass the most
menial average things laws related to
election security perhaps you should
have to have an id should perhaps we
should have more security about around
mail-in ballots perhaps people shouldn't
be able to canvas as you're waiting on
lines right outside a few little things
and by the way these same people who
think it's racist
to have to show an id to vote all want
you to have to show an id to go bowling
right they want you literally to have a
vaccine passport to walk into a bowling
alley that is not me besmirching the
good sport of bowling i love bowling the
last time i went bowling i think i had
an all-time high 181 pretty good that
was before covet i don't know if
bowling's been legal in this state for
the last two years but the point is he's
a liar everything he just said there's a
lie so what's her name the host
nicole wallace it's like she either is
an idiot a [ __ ] or a liar too why
didn't she say to him hello jason
johnson i heard everything you just said
there but can you give me the specifics
on how those republican laws are going
to stop anyone from voting
does anyone watching this know anyone
without an id michael you know anyone
without an id
oh yeah no he know everyone he knows has
an id he had to think about it for a
minute because you know some shady
characters connor anyone
you know all right he thinks maybe the
homeless guy that lives on his corner
that's funny that's funny doesn't have
an id these people are extraordinary
liars and they lie about everything not
something they lie about every single
thing